tour de vis des autorités néerlandaises
au quatrième jour de couvre-feu à
childéric à la haine c'est le retour à
l'accalmie dans ce quartier qui avait
cristallisé de nombreuses tensions
un important déploiement de policiers a
été mis en place
objectif éviter à tout prix les émeutes
anti couvre-feu qui ont fait rage les
trois dernières nuits hier le centre
ville de rotterdam s'est retrouvé
défiguré par les nuits de violence
magasins pillés vitrines brisées et
arrêt de bus cassés les habitants
constatent les dégâts avec amertume ce
ne pas se battre pour la liberté c'est
triste des gens pleurent parce qu'ils ne
se sentent plus à la maison
les manifestants protestent contre
l'instauration d'un couvre-feu entre 21h
et 4h30 du matin puni d'une amende de 95
euros c'est déjà plus de 1700
contrevenants qui auraient déjà été
verbalisées ces violences inédites dans
le pays depuis 40 ans se sont soldées
par l'arrestation de plus de 180
personnes
selon le chef de la police au moins 10
membres des forces de l'ordre ont été
blessés
ces émeutes n'ont rien à voir avec le
droit fondamental de manifester respect
pour tous les collègues qui ont eu du
mal pendant trois nuits et son côté le
premier ministre démissionnaire que ma
croûte eux a réagi en affirmant que 99%
des néerlandais soutiennent les mesures
restrictives de liberté pour commencer
ces émeutes sont inadmissibles et les
personnes normales s'en aperçoive avec
horreur
vous pouvez vraiment vous demandez ce
qui est passé par la tête de ces gens
cela n'a rien à voir avec de la
protestation
c'est de la violence criminelle et nous
la traiterons comme tel le gouvernement
assure qu'il ne fera pas marche arrière
malgré les protestations depuis le début
de la pandémie au moins treize mille six
cents personnes sont décédées du coït 19
aux pays bas